good morning millennium
morning Millennials Millennials say hi
to the Millennials what's up how's it
we're doing it's the last show before a
holiday and I just couldn't be more
excited for holiday hopefully I make it
to my holiday because as you know I'm
taking a seaplane with the points guy
and it's probably gonna go down don't
say that I'm gonna say whatever she's
gonna keep saying it's that it doesn't
happen I know your tactic no if you like
if you like our nervous about telling
then you don't say it like it's
definitely gonna happen but if you put
it out there it's not gonna happen right
it's always the thing you don't expect
that's gonna happen that's believersí
like your fights just gonna be delayed
of course if you're wondering why I was
filming our intro we are working on a
groundbreaking short film about the
behinds of scenes of the toast for
vanozza blog vlog a day in the life how
the toast gets made for our patreon
channel it should be up later today yes
our episode for this week is very
in-depth we look literally as I've been
filming this video since I woke up it
looks so ugly and then we'll come back
to early video our makeup how we got our
outfits how we get here what goes on
once we get here how we pick the stories
it's all gonna be in this first patreon
episode for July I'm really excited I
think it might win an award
yeah ooh I had heard that there was like
Oscar buzz but you know those things
sometimes don't pan out so you really
shouldn't shouldn't jinx it um yeah this
is our last show of the week I can't lie
I'm very excited to just like have some
time off we went to dinner last night
for Olivia's birthday and that's my
update what about you I was with you so
that's my update as well they served
Robin at the restaurant it was really
sad oh my god I wanted to order it just
to see what rabbit looks like like
that's so sad that's so sad Oh Bob it
should only be eaten if you're like in
the forest and like you could die where
do you even find a rabbit in New York
City I don't know I've never been to a
butcher I don't think rabbit even is
kosher
no that's why I wouldn't that's why I've
never seen it like a butcher but I've
never seen it on any other menu no me
neither
that would be that would be like equal
to seeing venison on a menu yeah I think
venison is more normal
because Iowa's all ladies of London hmm
I think rabbit is the equivalent of
squirrel yeah horse it's crazy
Tom Colicchio like there's a crazy man
that's not cool bro like seriously
so Jackson and I are
obviously here to deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast additionally we have a
very cool guest today if you didn't
recognize her name it's because she's
new on the scene she's new I said ten
o'clock last night Sternin followers
uh-huh
her name is Sophie Chanel now she's a BS
Nassif yes you know she was the winner
of last night's episode of the proposal
which is that terrible ABC show she was
giving us like moderate amount of tea
before the show and I think there's like
a lot that goes on behind the scenes
like you're gonna die basically it's
really crazy so we will do our show
deliver the Fast Five and then bring on
Sophie in a bit I'm so excited to talk
to her did you it's fascinating
she was an engaged woman from the
proposal it's so crazy we will get her
all of your questions but before that
here are the fast high stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
they met burst up Drake's new album
scorpions choppers shappers shatters
every Apple music record I haven't heard
a single song I'm just waiting for like
the one song that everyone loves that I
can like yeah I hide it's like I don't
have enough time on my talking I'm like
full of dan + Shay to listen to the
whole Drake album but like whatever
family it's like 25 songs right so
whatever like the equivalent of like
this one is like the most popular one
I'll listen to it I just need a verse to
decide it for me yeah and then I'll get
behind well usually like a NR decides
that for you and they release a single
but instead they just drop 25 songs on
you and it's a lot to take in
we accept I would have Olivia's birthday
dinner mm-hmm I was like sitting at
dinner I'm like my chin was getting
really itchy and I was like kept feeling
this bump and I'm we were out to dinner
for like two hours and I think literally
from the time I left my house to the
time I got home I grew a pimple and then
I got home and it was white and like
ready to go Wow and I popped it first of
all it was huge it splattered on the
mirror oh my god
and that all happened at dinner like is
that crazy I feel like people's take
like two days to come yeah that's really
is that the bump you kept telling
everyone to feel no no that's some
surgery conversations yeah
it's just an after as some sort or well
I'm happy for you and your chimp oh yeah
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you
what were you saying about A&R um that
he should have released a single so that
we know what the pocket song is what
Todd's plan I think that's true that's a
good song
but like I mean I'm not a huge fan so
this doesn't do that much for me but
like if Dan and Shea came out with a
twenty five song album I would be on the
floor crying so I don't know and like
did you see Dan and she's Instagram
they're planning because we we literally
us two made their album number one
streamed Billboard country album they
are releasing something on July 4th they
didn't say what it was they just put up
like a pink square on their Instagram I
don't know what that means but I'm
excited and I'm seeing them perform on
July 4th I wonder if they perform at
they I don't know kimly
tomorrow's ty 4th I know I'm working to
where I got I have nothing to do it so
annoying I am not in shape for life do
you want to feel like so bad for me I
place like a bomb ASOS order and it's
probably gonna arrive after I leave
today this always happens to you why
don't you just ship it to your
destination genius I don't know why I
didn't do that like it's a how it's
arriving today maybe I have a good
sister who will go and overnight it for
me I might okay I might tell my day
shakes out in what time is it delivers
yeah look how annoying why can't mail
like ever come in the morning or you
need to get it a ride to the Hamptons
with someone do you know anyone going
tonight I could drop it off oh okay
that's a good idea
look it's really important that I get
those connected to get it on a seaplane
we need to get it on a seaplane imagine
if you've got a ticket for just your
ASOS box they'll be amazing that's money
well spent
margos but you might as well buy
designer clothes never Margo is watching
from Desiree oh hey [ __ ]
hi snake just me miss you all right
let's jump in let's jump in we did jump
in and that was a bad story what was it
that Drake is smashing Apple music
record so it's kind of interesting
because he's up there with like Taylor
Swift Adele but can we just like put
things into perspective for why I like
Apple music has been a company for like
two years how many records can they have
that's true like Stevie Nicks isn't on
Apple bruh Apple music record I'm a
tribute I'm interested interested in
Spotify records yeah unlike iTunes like
real bill pays Apple music just
rebranded oh right remember when we
would buy every song that we wanted on
iTunes for dollar 29 we didn't know like
how bad we had it until like Spotify
came out and changed our lives and
people are like do you pay for premium
like nine dollars a month versus 129 for
every song that you want that's little
cry tears I got it for $4.99 a month
because if you're a student you can get
us about if I just count not a lot of
people know that you're welcome
email Spotify Premium is the best money
I've ever spent ever and I don't even
spend it at me and bensharon account Wow
but did you guys kick each other off
like very rarely are we listening to
music at the same exact time that's so
interesting
like he listens to it during the day at
work and I listen to it like in the
morning and like on the weekends huh
yeah no it's weird but I was actually
thinking the other day like I don't pay
for any services like we have a family
Netflix account I got some ones Hulu
account from my Instagram DMS same with
HBO GO
I'm uses Ben's spot if I look I don't
pay for any of those services yeah cuz
people are always like Hulu is this much
a month and like comparing it I'm like
it is I don't know how much necklace is
month we have a family account yeah and
we've had it forever and that's just a
hundred people the best money I have it
on 3G - about hats and what I have it on
three TVs and my lips should start
charging 100 dollars a month because I
would pay it but don't give them any
ideas but don't charge us that much
because we're getting India's yeah yeah
I want free Netflix for life we want to
be grandfathered in I love a good
grandfather Inc no I use I have a Hulu
Plus account first I was using Marco
fishes what do you watch they're nothing
but on the off chance that I'm looking
for something sometimes it's on Hulu do
you don't I mean yeah I feel like
everything well actually no everything
is on Amazon yeah Amazon is the best I
told you I got the fire stick yes it
should be arriving today I'm very
excited
that's exciting yeah okay next up great
news LuAnn de Lesseps celebrates six
months of sobriety I am so happy for her
LuAnn is six months sober taking to
Instagram the Real Housewives of New
York star celebrated the milestone with
her family including ex-husband count
Alexandre de Lesseps in Sag Harbor Watts
greatest reunion ever she said wonderful
to spend the weekend with the kids and
the count also counting my blessings
celebrating six months of sobriety happy
4th of July everyone but you know what
it is like I don't feel like LuAnn was
an alcoholic do you know what I mean I
feel like eventually she'll go back to
like drinking wine casually I don't
think that like she can't have a sip
without like needing to get blackout
like I just thought that like she was
drinking too much and like she needed a
break do you know anything I don't get
like alcoholic vibes I have this
conversation with you when I was
wondering because when you get arrested
or you got a DUI and you have to go to
rehab like to
to stop does that mean you're an
alcoholic cuz you got arrested or are
you just taking a break from drinking
right look sheikh efendi that's early
arab and i feel a break but like I don't
know I just feel like she needed to get
her head straight and like is it bad to
say like she can drink again like I
compare it to like Scott Disick like he
was destructive when he drank like every
single time like and you can he can't
have one drink without having a hundred
drinks so he's definitely someone who
should stop drinking altogether where's
like LuAnn she had one bad incident I
just I think she was a fine drinker
before like I don't know I'm just like I
keep watching the episodes I'm like is
she done drinking for good and I should
saying six months sobriety I don't know
like maybe she now she likes her sober
life and she realized ring he wasn't
doing anything for other than getting
her in trouble but so here's the thing
he's just a little T obviously because
someone in our group said they saw LuAnn
at pride and that she was like looking a
little drunk I don't know I might be
looking drunk too in the sand and
there's no heat yeah in a dress and like
full glam yeah but I don't expect her to
be a hundred percent sober no but she's
saying that she is right but I'm saying
like in my professional opinion the
countess can have a glass of wine at
dinner yes but we also don't know her
that well but sometimes like I've had
friends I've had friends who have had to
stop drinking completely it's like a
chemical thing but I've also had friends
who have had to stop drinking because it
was getting them into trouble and then
years later they can now drink again in
moderation yeah I just think probably
going through emotional turmoil and
being a heavy drinker is not a good
pairing but like once she's out of the
woods with the Tom stuff I think she'll
be okay to drink I don't know I don't
know I don't think so okay I just think
I don't think we really understand
alcoholism yeah that's definitely true
so we're just going off of what we see
on TV which is fraudulent right actually
just watch the most recent episode of
Renee from last week the grace Mayflower
which we have to go look so glamorous
it's definitely so expensive that's all
I was thinking about so many thoughts
LuAnn Bethenny Sonja laying in a bed
being best friends is everything I need
in this life but it's like equivalent to
Lisa Rinna and Erika Jayne friendship I
get it no I needed it and having
Davidson yeah now that I have it I don't
want anything else
mhm um that dinner was horrible like on
so many levels I actually weirdly
believed Ramona when she like had an ax
at the dinner table and was like oh I
don't think she understood by heaven was
yelling at her for taking the picture
and then once it was literally explained
to her like a child like I think she
actually felt bad I don't think she
realized like the PR element oh I
totally disagree from the minute she did
it I think she wanted to be the first
person to post a picture with LuAnn I
don't think she understood how terrible
that was but I think she was being
thirsty wanted to like everyone to come
to her Instagram to see what winds up to
and like wanted to get all of the likes
okay fine
but like in actuality there was no wine
on the table there were wine glasses
it's a restaurant it sounds terrible but
LuAnn no one knew that she even left
rehab so here Ramona is the press
release and not only did she leave rehab
she's up filming with the girls back to
what would look like to maybe a court
back to her old ways also people are
saying a lot of times when you get
drinking charges you are required to
quit drinking by the courts all she has
to say sober for court I don't know I
mean you just submit to like alcohol
okay that's fair breathalyzer test yeah
so probably until she's out of the woods
on the legal stuff she has to stay sober
okay
so many conversations at that dinner
were so explosive like and I know you
love her but like I'm really like
getting over Tinsley like she's being
such a Whitney I don't love her like
she's not my favorite by any means I
just felt like she added a different
flavor to the show like something a
little younger and sillier and I don't
like when she gets in fights because she
can't hold her own at all but like
sometimes when she's just having a fun
moment being elyes at the Marmara yeah I
agree it's cute but like her and Karl's
friendship is really pissing me off I
agree they're so like stubborn and
there's their Mean Girls and like
they're taking this it's like damn in
jorinda against the other three girls
it's like they're totally gonna be the
three couches at the Reunion and I just
like I can't stand Carole and I can't
stand Tinsley and I think that like they
just look for reasons to be mad at
Bethenny like what Bethenny said about
the coffin was absolutely hilarious and
totally true
and Tinsley was like you're comparing
marriage to death no no that's not she
totally missed the metaphor the metaphor
is like you're not dead yet but you're
shopping for a coffin you're not even
engaged yet but you're shopping for a
wedding dress and then Carole coming in
and being like we went to Harry Winston
like that's so [ __ ] because like when
you're in a relationship you're allowed
to look at a serious relationship you're
allowed to look at what a neuterings
being in a serious relationship and
looking at engaged
it's the same thing as being engaged and
looking at wedding dresses it is the
next step but 20 step to step yeah that
was when Tinsley trying on wedding
dresses like for me that was actually a
transformative moment where I was like
she was knocked down many pegs and then
she like oh my god wait someone just DM
the chose I'm driving from Midtown to
Southampton around 5:00 p.m. and I'm
happy to bring you your ASOS someone GM
does Alexandra oh my god okay I got in
touch with her okay also I feel like a
lot of the women are harboring residual
anger against Bethenny and they're
bringing it out now because they they
seized upon she's down and wounded and
it's a pile on it and it's not
applicable to what's actually happening
I totally agree and I like I feel for
Bethenny like I'm not here for for
pile-ons especially when they're unlike
not deserving like I can really use like
a Duren to pile on because like she's
out of control
also in Dorinda like interview she's
always saying finally I did something
Bethenny couldn't do like so I'm
obsessed with that she sips everyone is
obsessed with like one upping Bethenny
it's like they know that she's better
than them but if you know something's
better than you like don't say it yeah
just like know your place and just like
accept it right then it's just a weird
social I totally agree Dorinda side
interviews drive me insane she makes no
sense she like I can't believe that
there's not more coming for Dorinda
because like oh like when she came for
Sonja and her family crest so mean and
like literally finally Sonja was able to
have a cohesive argument and she like
shut it down completely but like so
Dorinda is obsessed with Sonja mm-hmm
obsessed with Sonja so much so it makes
me think like why she's so obsessed and
so yeah I think she sees herself and
Sonja and I think like Jurina is a
little bit of a Sonia but everyone just
like its own you [ __ ] for like living in
the past and that's really what drove us
all the women all the women do all of
them it's just like I can't believe
there's not more of a like in the
audience and on the show like more of a
wanting for like I take town of Dorinda
you know everyone's time copies and he
loves her and also a lot of Dorinda like
what she's doing is in her interviews so
the women haven't seen it yet right and
maybe the reunion will be at the moment
I don't think so like I think remember
but that's not all her in the village
idiot and that's exactly what you and
Bethenny got off scot-free there was
about to be a pylon and like Ramona
called her and
not tracker thing but then Luanne got
arrested to let you got a break now that
legs are all back I think the coming
verge of Bethany that hasn't even
started and that conversation next week
where she carols like she goes to Carly
I just don't think you'd like me
I'm proud like well maybe that's it I
can't I can't
and I shan't but I am happy for Luanne
it's it's the season of Luanne which is
so crazy considering it's the season she
got arrested but it's also like this
season of her justice being served yeah
it's like she's so normal
she's so normal and she's had a full 360
actually no 180 on the show and it's
like everyone sees it like everyone's
like wow LuAnn and like these women like
every time someone like [ __ ] up they
don't want them side so everyone is
basically being like consistently saying
LuAnn is like a different person and I'm
really happy for she's like I'm her I'm
a LuAnn Stan lol his staff understand I
stand when saying okay next up Jersey
Shore's Deena Cortese is pregnant
expecting a baby boy with Christopher
Buckner she's cute so cute the Jersey
Shore star announced on Instagram Monday
that she's expecting her first child
with her husband Chris and I decided to
wait until we were ready to spill the
beans Deena captioned a series of
pregnancy reveal pictures taken by magic
toast photography shout-out to that
magic toast they did a really cute baby
announcement like that was fourth of
July themed did you see their Instagram
yes like fireworks we're so excited to
say little firecrackers on the way that
it's definitely gonna be a firecracker
yeah but like this is like a two-fold
type of thing because like I'm so happy
for Deena I'm so happy like her meatball
days are over like she's finally like I
love her own but like this just makes
the show that much lamer like I know
that's so mean to say but like now it's
just another person with kids who's
gonna start right on me crying at a
restaurant cuz they miss their kids you
know anything but I think that they
bring their kids to the filming this
next season I think well they're in
Vegas
and now they're back at the Jersey Shore
I think their kids came to the shore
came to the shore wow that is a world
one and Deena was not in Vegas probably
and people were saying because she was
pregnant and she is pregnant Oh totally
but I'm happy that like they're back in
the limelight so that Gina can like give
her kid like a nice life and I her and
financially support the kid maybe send
her to private school or something they
need to stay at the shore yeah forever I
don't know Vegas I'm you know how I feel
about I know but this I can come but
Vegas could be different because it's
like paulie's hometown now
she runs it and Ronnie yeah but like
Ronnie nobody Chen is gonna be Oh on the
outskirts of town with their baby that's
actually interesting even though he's a
horrible person did you see this
follow-up photos from TMZ of the car
with the blood everywhere like insane
how are people not bid called I don't
know but how like are you really gonna
drag someone with your car like you'd go
to jail she isn't you know she is she
was sorry she got out I'm sure she
posted bail oh my goodness that's so
crazy I know what a crazy world we live
in like that that's not only that is
that happening it's honor time like
these are the people that we watched on
TV know we glorify animals look at us
I'm gonna we're like koalas yeah cuties
little pudgy little pudgy okay
next story we decided to switch it up
because I truly am tired of talking
about the same things over I couldn't
agree more so where's this article from
this article is from cheddar Wow why
this heatwave is particularly dangerous
tell me I know why it's dangerous I'm
going to have a [ __ ] heat stroke the
hottest month of the year just got a
whole lot hotter most of the u.s. is
being blanketed by a scorching heat wave
with temperatures for half of the lower
48 states exceeding 90 degrees
Fahrenheit and feeling even hotter if
you go anywhere from Virginia up to
Maine there is no region you can find
that doesn't feel like a hundred degrees
says Andrew Friedman science editor at
Axios we should have him on the show an
expert I'd be like hey Simon what was
his name Andrew Andrew how to get rid of
chub-rub
what's particularly disturbing for
climate scientists is that in some areas
temperatures didn't fall below 80
degrees at night climate scientists are
looking at warming nights warming faster
than days and that's consistent with
climate change said Rieman heat
advisories and excessive heat warnings
are in fact so thanks to a so-called
heat dome Anam usually intense area of
high pressure that keeps regions under
its influence sunny and storm free well
storm freedom man Leonardo DiCaprio
wrote this article perhaps or like he's
reading it right now or more likely he's
watching the show right now worth
knowing we'd be talking honestly like
it's so unbearable and I can't
I literally this entire summer have
probably spent an accumulative
30 minutes outside just between like
walking into my apartment walking out
to an uber like I refuse to spend time
outside I've been trying to like walk
and spend time outside just get the
blood flowing the lymphatic nodes on
fleek uh but this heat wave is really
cramping my style and I guess I'll have
to stay home with zero steps no it's
like my air conditioners are working
overtime I think they're about to break
Claudia what Aaron Pakman said try being
seven months pregnant in this weather
okay I was okay so I was on Instagram
yesterday and I saw Instagram story of
Stephanie Gottlieb the jewelry designer
who's pregnant she was like three out of
the four ACS in my apartment building
are out and I was like oh my god oh my
god and I was thinking like oh my god
she's pregnant and I was like holy [ __ ]
I literally was trying to do the math of
like when when's ideal time to get
pregnant so that you're not pregnant in
the summer I'd rather have a baby in the
September September than nine months is
May okay
soon you miss the whole summer yeah
fantastic or you get pregnant like in
June and that's over certain months the
purse seemed a good idea but it's crazy
that we live in a time with
air-conditioning like I remember in the
movie The Great Gatsby like they don't
have a/c so when it's really hot out
they like go to a hotel and like keep
ordering ice and what are those do like
to make them cooler or they go to the
hotel that has a/c because it's like
just becoming or I'm watching Mad Men
and like the I told you they don't like
how they see in their homes yet they're
still thinking about it
but we are privy to all of this air
conditioning and we're still struck like
no I feel not enough that and I would
literally wake up every day grateful
that I was born in 2018 like I can could
not survive in an era without air
conditioning it's so like people must
have had the sweatiest brows well for
their been fans for a while but you are
better
uh-huh and like a fan like this yeah but
you know those are actually
counterproductive because the energy you
use to move your arm just makes you
hotter but then you're calling it it's
like you stay the same temperature
really yeah it's like you're putting all
this energy into moving your wrist
therefore making yourself hotter but
then you're also cooling yourself down
with the air you're generating so it's
like you're staying at the same
temperature okay just a little math for
you but then also think of Theo like he
has a coat of fur and it's 100 degrees
but he's not as affected by temperature
as humans are I think Haley
like he loves to like bathe in the heat
like he just lays out in my part
my room that's in the Sun oh my god I
didn't know that I mean he's so cute I
hope he's having a good day he's in the
Hamptons I can't I literally have missed
him so much and you know like I have
this genuine like fear of being alone
but Ben and C and that really has been
fixed was like I've been out for work or
if like if I end up sleeping home alone
every once in a while
Theo really helps like I feel like I'm
not alone and if I hear a sound and I
think I'm being crazy and Theo here is
it - I'm like okay I'm not being crazy
you know so funny every time here sounds
like so most pointless for me uh so last
night I was without do and without Ben
and like I was legitimately petrified I
stopped with the lights on well maybe if
you ever came to my apartment because I
live around the block from you and I
would provide shelter for you yeah she
has still never been to my apartment
okay
and I live around the block from her how
long have you lived there I have lived
there since late no sorry
March so three months March April May
June July almost high force for the
first two months and you didn't want
anyone to come you didn't have any
theater so I've only been dodging you
for about two months but like in those
two months I've come to your apartment
so many times but the thing is we live
too close to each other for me to take a
cab - Ben from your apartment so I know
that the part I have to walk and the
walk is two and a half blocks of like
first of all filth because I walk Theo
and I'm like constantly looking at the
ground there's just garbage everywhere
and in the heat like I just can't make
it I would prefer you lived like two
miles away so that I could take an uber
a nurse if you look two miles but it
would live at your house I got to be
there every day well that's so sad like
I go to Olivia Margo's all the time was
that so I just take a cab to my
apartment fine I won't judge you find
directions wise it makes it does anyways
this heatwave it's particularly
dangerous says cheddar I mean I went on
cheddar TV and they did not tell me this
make sure forget drinking a lot of water
you guys I'm not doing and I'm not I
looked at my face the other day and I
wondered why like I looked so terrible
and it's because I'm not doing enough
water yeah even though like water is a
total sham it's really a show not a job
okay okay what the next phase and final
story another one we're changing up I
really I'm I don't know if this is gonna
be a permanent change but like I'm
really enjoying talking about things
other than a connect and Markel
Khloe Kardashian and Arianna know like
it's like I've exhausted myself to the
point where I have new interests like
yesterday we talked about LeBron going
to the Lakers that I donated and it
opened up a whole new pocket of my brain
that I don't use uh-huh
speaking of Amazon is expanding prime
day reports CNN Money that's exciting
Amazon Prime day is growing to a
day-and-a-half Amazon is expanding its
savings event for Prime members to 36
hours six hours longer than last year it
will start on July 16th not on my
birthday Puck
it will start on July 16th at 3 p.m.
Eastern Time Amazon is promising more
than a million deals around the world
Amazon uses the data create buzz gin up
sales and recruit more people into a
program many shoppers already considered
indispensable indispensable last year's
prime day was the biggest sales day in
Amazon's history the company didn't give
specifics but said tens of millions of
Prime members bought something so even
if all them only spent $5 that's 50
million dollars in the day Prime has
more than a hundred million members so
even if all of them spend $5 Wow five
hundred million single Jimmy I don't
know um I'm glad they're expanding prime
day because I feel like I was find out
about it too late and then by the time I
figure out what I want I go and the day
is over no last year I was very nervous
about prime day I just bought my first
Alexa and a vacuum this year I'm getting
two more Lexus because I want one in my
bathroom and in my bedroom I'm getting
uh another firestick pending that I like
the first one I'm just I'm getting
everything like I'm not holding back
I've been saving like items in my cart
even just at random like nail polishes
that I don't need them up by until til
primetime day but I feel like the random
stuff that I buy on Amazon is not prime
oh I only purchase prime things well now
I need to think of what I need to start
making a lot of makeup and it's all your
price and then they also do like special
flash sales right every hour so I always
go look at those maybe she gets more
further and it's really stuff like I
don't need no you she had some orange
let's think of what the total cooler
what is Theo need on Friday the toast
needs some bookshelves like on this pink
wall with like memorabilia well we have
the the sign coming soon yeah we've been
me outside the summit coming like this
week I'm really excited about that but
if we had like bookshelves like floating
shelves in the back that we could put
like like the clubhouse like our gabbles
things people have got us like I got so
many
cute gifts at my meet and greet like
this big piece of toast like just like
random [ __ ] okay boom but that wouldn't
make it like to change like I don't get
up I don't know we'll see we all have to
experiment anyways I feel like we should
do a master post like on our Instagram
where people can suggest what you should
get on prime day because I need
inspiration oh that's a good idea
because I need immunization and like
people are like animals when it comes to
Amazon and there's always a master
posting the toasters of Amazon products
that have changed people's limy and I am
interested in being an Amazon product
that I thought was gonna change my life
was that double chin exerciser
unfortunately didn't work because I
never used it and because I broke it
like the second I got it well now you
have a new chin now I don't need it it
may be an inspire it did change but
because it inspired you to get a new
chant it did and how is new chin going
new chin is definitely changed my
perspective a little like I filmed a
YouTube video today and my tripod was
like so low that like I still had a
double chin because like no one can be
filmed from that angle without it but it
was definitely better that's so exciting
I'm very excited for you I have a new
forehead and it's not a new chin but
cross your eyebrows was it well it's
amazing before we bring out our guest
let's go through a few housekeeping
announcements because we will not be
seeing you guys until Monday very sad
that is really sad that's a long time
use it wisely everyone yes we are
working on like we said our first patron
episode of July and is going to be
behind the scenes of the toast all the
post gets made if you are interested go
to patreon.com/scishow morning toast and
become a patron what else what else I
feel like so much stuff happened
yesterday like totally related no I
don't know just toast related I feel
like I'm just getting so excited about
cam toast it's just an amazing nap
yesterday like that's all I can think
about how long only an hour because I
knew wait to go to Libya's dinner and I
was like dozing off in the middle of
bluebloods
it was fantastic I did not watch The
Bachelor even though I said I want to be
because we got back from dinner so late
and then I had a bunch of a proposal
because that was more important okay
speaking of the proposal we're about to
bring out Sophie she no Sophia no excuse
me who won last night's episode we think
she's an engaged woman I'm very very
excited to just ask her a million
questions about this very dumb show so
if you have questions for Sophia about
behind the scenes stuff about her
relationship about casting about
whatever feel free to comment on the
YouTube or the Facebook streams because
that's where I'm a watching and
we will be right back we'll see you in a
few
you
okay we are back with Sofia Chenault
whom I assumed was an engaged woman but
you're an assassin jewelry I do not have
a ring on this finger as of now and why
is that so basically things between me
and Steven did not work out
so we went on the show we flew back to
New Orleans together because we're both
from there and we tried to make it work
I met his parents he met my parents he
met all my friends at school he's
amazing and we had the best time just
like the timing was not really working
out I was graduating from college moving
back to New York where I live now and it
just the timing wasn't going to work but
I like have nothing bad to say about
writing so awesome how long were you
guys together after the show so we were
together for a very short amount of time
after the show probably like under two
weeks said he had time to meet you had
time to meet his parents your parents
your friends yeah I'm so right away we
kind of I mean we were engaged
so it was like backtracking basic right
but so I met his parents right away and
I met his dad on the show what she saw
and then when we kind of ended things we
maintained our friendships we were still
friends and over graduation my parents
came down to New Orleans and I was like
well my parents kind of want to meet my
fiance fiance so honor you coming out to
dinner with that that's so funny and so
you had gotten a Neil Lane ring on the
show and you had to return it after the
two weeks yeah actually I was not I was
never really allowed to wear it why
because people think I wasn't supposed
to be telling people I was engaged right
so realistically if you guys had
something together now you probably
would have just gotten the ring right
like it was supposed to be shipped like
a few days ago that's so funny
do you have any say in what ring was
being chosen
I had no certain what ring was it it was
an yelling ring and
was beautiful I literally had like maybe
three minutes to stare at it so I
couldn't tell you much about it that's
so sad I know it's sad and us still talk
yeah all the time really talk last night
we talked like almost like every day
especially as the show was not yeah like
he was super nervous I was super nervous
but my dad called him actually right
after the show finished last night ten
Hoosick Stephen what's up buddy
do you ever think you would get back
together cuz it sounds like you guys are
really sweet
um I mean anything's possible and never
know if we're gonna be in the same place
again but for now we're just kind of
friend his friend and so how did one how
do you get on the show like what was the
casting process like did they reach out
to you so yeah they reached out to me
one of the casting producers like on
Instagram on Facebook actually and she
said hey Sofia like found your profile I
like your look like would you be
interested and so like I'm a huge
bathroom man like you guys love that
stuff and I was with all my friends at
school and we were like sitting on a
couch just like should we do it should I
do it and they're like Sofia you're
doing it that means we're all doing it
right so we're all kind of like filling
out the application like laughing a
little like having fun with it and then
we want from there that's so crazy and
then you won like hilarious and you sang
I say an original song is that I have a
really great voice were you nervous to
sing in front of yeah
I mean nervous to sing but also like I
was in a bathing suit you know that made
it a little such [ __ ] like well the
whole show is really really crazy yeah
and I can't even imagine what it's like
to be there because it's a pageant of
women and like it you have a bikini
contest one of the women is scalloped
fingers from The Bachelor
your friend you trigger the final two
yes we were the final two how did she
end up on the show did she say so she
said that they reached out to her she is
like a great relationship with ABC they
love her and makes one person she was
like why not like you know like I was
outside out yeah but I
I actually love her we have like a good
friendship and she I was super nervous
to be on the show I had never done
anything like this and she was kind of
like helping me backstage and like
helped me after she's like you're gonna
be okay
yeah she's I do like her she's a nice
girl so it must be new for you to like
have people know who you are and like
follow you on Instagram and I'm sure you
got you know your average sized amount
of hate just for being on TV last night
what what are what is the response from
people like what are you getting so most
of the tweets right now are like Sophia
has homework to do ring break because
I'm so young I'm 22 so fun but how will
this even 27 so the crazy not bad people
are so annoying yeah I mean I'm so
sensitive so I'm it's a hard time really
like read it read it exactly I'm just
like trying to avoid it but I mean most
people are being nice but you know
Kristen has a really really strong fan
base right from the show from being on
The Bachelor and being on bachelor in
paradise so a lot of people are like you
know he should have picked Kristen each
other pick Kristen but I mean I really
like her so I have nothing bad to say
about her but um yeah would you ever go
on The Bachelor now um I'm still so
young like I'm 22 girls are getting
younger yeah right like Kerwin was 24
yeah Curren was super young I mean I
would consider it maybe within the next
like few years yeah but this was kind of
just like for fun yeah and I had so much
fun dude was it like crazy being like
going home being engaged flying home
with your fiance and like then finding
out his last name and all of the yeah I
mean actually after it happened he bent
down on one knee and gave me his cell
phone was like but you please address
thank you where does he live he lives in
New Orleans so did they cast people
purposely who were in New Orleans no it
was just coincidence yeah it was a real
incident and like I was the only one
from New Orleans right but it was really
like nice because we got to go back
together yeah I got to meet his family
right
and he kind of like showed me his side
of New Orleans because I like obviously
had a different experience going to
college there but yeah when was this
film like do you have to take off class
or so I was part time second semester
which was nice so I had a lot of free
time I flew to LA in end of April and I
was there for like three and oh so
that's recent
yeah pretty recent so how long did the
actual filming of the episode take like
a day um yeah a few hours oh yeah he's
hot he's so cute he's definitely
good-looking yeah is he a diva yeah yeah
I totally get that by promoting he's
like he's super 90s like just he was
into his role yeah like I'm the HOS he
was acting he was like I I'm just you
know I'm concentrating right now that is
so funny okay we have so many questions
for you so I'm just gonna kind of rapid
fire from or instrum the about a lot of
them are ones that we already asked um
so he is kind of a weird hugger
Steven on the show I don't know if did
you talk what's up yeah I didn't notice
so what's notes does he kiss as bad as
he hugs no I have a weird question you
don't have to answer like did you guys
have sex no you didn't right cuz like
you just yeah we just met it's so weird
that like you've never had sex meet
Beyonce I know but like it was you know
we came back right weren't going off
saying we're engaged right I kind of
introduced like him to my friends oh
this is Steven do not tell your friends
no I did tell them because it was like
how am I know yeah so the friends that
you applied with did any of them get on
in the other episodes that we should
know about that want to come on our show
after their episode oh they didn't they
didn't apply they were helping me oh I
thought they applied oh yeah they should
apply
totally so this shows little awkward in
general but then when Steven chose you
like there's no real protocol for what
like the other person is supposed to do
so it's a little weird watching last
night like Kristen was kind of lingering
and then left did they tell you what you
should do
like in those situations they kind of
said okay so if he doesn't pick you
you're just gonna exit this way so there
was not a
out of direction so I mean all of us
were like freaking out like what are we
gonna do because we're I mean it's just
awkward
yeah what are you sipping the whole
thing is weird printed any of the other
girls who were there yeah all of them
actually yeah we all are in a group chat
it's called proposal babes it's so fun
um we yeah we're all friends like right
after it all happened I came back to the
hotel and like we all got drinks
together and like I said like everyone's
so nice was anyone like really
heartbroken no how can you be hardly an
anonymous loser they tell you about him
before it started nothing that's okay
like they didn't even tell us his name I
was like begging them to tell me like
what color hair does we have like how
old does he like I didn't know anything
and then what would you have done is
like they turned him around and you're
not interested
I wouldn't like I was interested when
you came out I was like you look great
like he was so smiley he was so nice and
like I was I was just like so caught up
in the moment it was like I didn't even
know what was happening I feel like I
blacked out but your own hair makeup so
I came in with a bass uh-huh they're
like what do you what look are you going
for and then they kind of touched it up
okay that's good your hair and makeup
looked amazing thank you and all of your
outfits were on point thank you or did
you go shopping before my mom's store
relax Sag Harbor check it out I'll go
this weekend yeah yeah no you sure wore
the cutest white dress I was like so
Bridal
I understood the tones yeah and then I
think you were like a one-piece bathing
suit yes solid and striped red white and
blue with your guitar and sneakers
sneakers what would you do so I just
graduated from college and I'm kind of
on the job hunt right now this was like
a little bit of a distraction but I'm
currently applying to all jobs and
entertainment marketing
I was trying real estate I'd write know
what I want to do is I'm not gonna lie
and say I do but I'm really trying
everything but you also say no yeah like
that so she bends dad telling you
well thank you so much for joining us
bury your soul on ABC I really hope you
on the back tire oh that would be great
yeah you should I think it'd be great
I'm 22 the alive enjoy you're saying
that you looked like Lauren Ari's fiance
you give me Corinne vibes with the hair
- yeah I'm the show you look like her a
little bit better in person
you're your own girl oh thank you I'm
sorry that it didn't work out with the
seedbed but if anyone watching this show
knows a nice girl
ha I mean boy oh my god sorry whoa
after everything that you've said like I
kind of ship you and Stephen and I'm
rooting for the two of you really yeah
and I want you to get that nailing right
yeah me too right
I mean I'll keep you updated Thank You
Josh follow up with Sophie on Instagram
to see if she ever got back with Stephen
yeah what people saw you up with with my
Instagram is at Sofia Chanel Sh seh Oh
II na you that's a top a German yes how
do you know that everyone on the list I
did sale linguistics of the world okay
guys I was her last show before the
holiday weekend we hope everyone is an
amazing day celebrating this great
nation um I just want to say one more
thing Sarah this Kanye article in The
New York Times did you see it I just
want to say it's hard well like I just
want to get ready they did a whole
interview with him they followed him to
Wyoming it's like this in-depth article
where first of all they don't write any
of the curse words they write expletive
it's just like takes away from half the
article setting the ball like they're
using such big words and it's like it's
not that serious
um obviously it was a terrible article
and I want the person to room who wrote
it to know that they did a bad job cuz I
wanted to put it out there like first of
all just it's bad like it's a bad
article I was bored and it's like it
couldn't be more interesting that's so
crazy that I didn't even see that
and we were just saying like the World
Cup happened the other day and I didn't
even know about it I think it's good not
on Twitter yeah no that's it's everyone
is I got it from Pontius Twitter it's a
terrible article like just as a consumer
who enjoys pop culture and enjoys like
what goes on in the world like to have
read it and been incredibly bored and
not understand half the words in it
because it was either expletive or
because it was a word like the news was
made up I just want to say I want
everyone to know that I thought the
article was really poorly done so you
don't have to waste your time reading it
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the morning trusses the
Millennial morning show that goes live
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time Monday through
Friday we live few month a folks to make
sure you like us and we also live stream
on YouTube so make sure you're
subscribed and if you're a commuter and
watching is not your thing feel free to
head over to the podcasts or insert the
morning toast on podcast app leave us
five star review when you can listen to
all of our episodes there peace
you